protect our health and ensure the
dignity
of our professions
and of course we all owe
health workers an enormous debt not just
because they have cared for the sick
but because they have risked their own
lives
in the line of duty so far
about 10 percent of all cases globally
are among health workers
many health workers are also suffering
physical and psychological exhaustion
after months of working in
extremely stressful environments
to support health workers who has
published guidance
and training packages on how they can
protect themselves
we're also driving research to better
understand the extent of
infection among health workers and the
risk factors
for infection we're also shipping
millions of items of protective gear
around the world
and ensuring health facilities are
properly equipped
although covet 19 has rightly captured
the world's attention we must also
remember
it's not the only crisis the world
is facing many countries especially in
africa and the middle east are still
reeling from years of conflict
and other humanitarian crisis kobe 19
threatens
to exacerbate many of these crises
the pandemic and the restrictions put in
place to suppress it
are taking a heavy toll on
220 million people in protracted
emergencies while it's too early to
assess the full impact of
so-called lockdowns and other
containment measures
up to 132 million more people may go
hungry in 2020
in addition to the 690 million who went
hungry last year deep budget cuts to
education
and rising poverty caused by the
pandemic could force
at least 9.7 million children out of
school
forever by the end of this year with
millions more
falling behind in learning
the economic impact of the pandemic in
humanitarian settings
can aggravate already dire living
conditions
more displacement food shortages risk of
malnutrition
decrease in access to essential services
mental health problems
and so on the who is working through our
150 country offices
to support the response to covet 19
to support the continuity of essential
health services
and to engage communities to ensure
demand for these services
is maintained it's also vital
that as an international community we
use this opportunity
not only to respond to the pandemic but
to build health systems
that are more resilient and more able to
withstand
the impact of health emergencies
the pandemic is teaching us that health
is not a luxury item it is
the foundation of social economic
and political stability
three months ago who launched its
updated strategic preparedness and
response
plan which estimates the resources
needed to support who's work on the
pandemic
but we all know that the impacts of the
pandemic
go far beyond health and so do the
needs especially for the poorest
and most vulnerable countries
that's why the un launched the global
humanitarian response plan for kovid 19
in march today i'm honored to welcome
mark lowcock my friend the united
nations under secretary general for
humanitarian affairs
and emergency relief coordinator to
present
the global humanitarian response plan
update
the global humanitarian response plan
addresses the
immediate humanitarian needs caused or
exacerbated by covet 19
in 63 priority countries with existing
humanitarian crisis
if we fail to address the wider impacts
of the pandemic
we risk an even greater crisis than the
one brought about
by the virus itself mark
thank you for joining us today over to
you
well ted ross um thank you
thank you very much indeed it's great to
see you great to see mike with you
also by the way i don't think i've seen
mike since the day before yesterday
so it's i'm very pleased to um to be
with you and i'm i'm
um very um glad
also to have this opportunity to um
say thank you to everyone in the
professional media
who's been covering the um pandemic i
think that by and large
um the world has benefited from
professional coverage
um of a pandemic and i'm grateful to
responsible journalists
um for their role in that so as ted ross
has said today we publish
the third version of the
uh un kovid 19 global humanitarian
response plan for the first plan in
march we sought
two billion dollars the may update was
costed at 6.7 billion dollars
and funding the plan we're releasing
today will cost 10.3
billion dollars and you can see that in
a way as a metaphor
for the explosive impact of the virus so
i will run through the key elements of
the plan itself but
first and perhaps even more importantly
i want to talk a bit about
our estimates of the cost of doing
nothing
in these poor and fragile countries
because kobe 19 and the associated
global recession
are about to wreak havoc in fragile and
low-income
countries and my message today
especially in the run-up to the
g20 finance ministers meeting to them
and to other
rich nations is that unless we act now
we should be prepared for a series of
human tragedies
more brutal and more destructive than
any of the direct
impacts of the virus itself in action
as ted ross and others have been stating
very clearly in recent months
will leave the virus free to circle the
globe it will
undo decades of development and it will
create a generations worth of tragic
and exportable problems but it doesn't
have to be like that
this can be fixed with money and
leadership from the world's wealthier
nations and some fresh thinking
we estimate that the cost of protecting
the poorest 10 percent of the global
population from the worst effects of the
pandemic and the global recession
is about 90 billion dollars that's less
than one percent of the stimulus package
wealthy countries have put in place to
protect the global economy
today's plan is an important part of
that solution for 10.3 billion dollars
it will help 63 vulnerable countries and
cover the global transport system
necessary to deliver the relief
so why should wealthier countries fund
this
well my office working with the
university of oxford has produced the
first comprehensive and detailed
assessment
of the costs of inaction and i want to
highlight
three of its conclusions first the human
and economic costs of increased poverty
and hunger the pandemic
risks inducing the first rise in global
poverty
since 1990 at least 70 to 100 million
people
could be pushed back into the extreme
poverty category
in addition an extra 130 million people
could be pushed to the brink of
starvation by the end of this year
bringing the total to 265 million people
a doubling of people facing starvation
secondly there's the economic costs of
protracted containment measures on
education
a protracted school shutdown of five
months could generate learning losses
that have a present value
of 10 trillion dollars globally the
average student losing out on five
months of education could face a
reduction of sixteen thousand dollars in
lifetime earnings
in present value terms school closures
threaten not only education but also
nutrition
and they make girls more vulnerable for
example during the 2014-16 ebola
epidemic in west africa school closures
led to an increase in teenage
pregnancies of 11 percentage points
in sierra leone communities
thirdly there's the cost of increased
global instability and conflict
an additional 13 countries are projected
to experience
new conflicts between 2020 and 2022
relative to pre-pandemic forecasts if
that materializes
global instability would reach a new
30-year peak
conflict is expensive the minimum cost
incurred during an average civil war to
both host and neighbouring countries
has been estimated at approximately 60
billion dollars
refugee outflows would likely increase
the world food program calculates that
for each percentage point
increase in acute hunger refugee
outflows
increased by two percentage points
so let me come on now to the plan we're
releasing today and let me take the
opportunity to thank
hundreds probably thousands of
colleagues across humanitarian agencies
across the world health organization
through our food programme unicef
hundreds of ngos who've contributed to
the
update of the plan for their work the
main components making up the
10.3 billion dollars are 8.4 billion
for country level responses 1.8 billion
for global requirements including
more than a billion dollars for
humanitarian air transport getting aid
workers in the now getting supplies in
and out
and for our medical evacuation system
for
medical workers and aid workers working
for international organizations who get
sick
there's 300 million dollars in
supplemental funding for
ngos in addition to what we've got for
ngos in the country plans
ngos to benefit from something like 30
to 40 percent of all the resources
directly and indirectly we have in the
plan
but we need an additional allocation for
them to account for the fact that many
of them face acute funding problems now
and we have to keep these crucial ngos
in business because they play such an
important role in the frontline response
there's also 500 million dollars for
famine prevention there's a serious risk
of multiple famines later this year and
early next year
and we need to invest now to prevent
that
the plan obviously is only as effective
as the funding it receives
so far we've raised 1.7 billion dollars
i appreciate every country is being hurt
by this pandemic
but i do have to say that the response
of wealthy nations who have
rightly thrown out the fiscal and
monetary rule books to present to
protect their people
and their economies their response has
been grossly inadequate
when it comes to helping the poorer
countries and that is dangerously
short-sighted
the massive problem the world faces can
be addressed
with relatively little money with a
modicum of
imagination and if we park the old rules
to reflect today's unique circumstances
thank you very much indeed
thank you so much mr lokok and thank you
thank you thank you mark
apologies would you like to go say some
more words dr tuttle
no sorry my apologies for being too
quick now
we will move um on to the question and
answer
session as i mentioned both speakers are
now ready as most speakers you've heard
are now ready to answer your questions
but they are also joined by
dr mike ryan and dr maria von kirkov
our regular experts
now remember you can ask your question
in any of the un languages
as well as portuguese please state your
name and your agency and who your
question is for
however as i said we have so much
expertise in the room
someone else may answer now the first
person
i have on my list is sophie from
the south african broadcasting
commission sophie could you please
unmute yourself and go ahead
i have on my list is sophie from
the south african broadcasting
commission sophie could you please
unleash yourself and go ahead
thank you my question is directed to
the secret to the who director dr tedros
dr tedros uh tomorrow is nelson and
dallas day i just want to find out
your message to the globe or the world
during this time where we
are dealing with the problem of
covert 19 and on the
issue of um the impact of
this pandemic i just want to find out
the speaker just
pointed out that the wealthy nations
must come on board are you getting a
sense that there is
political commitment to assist foreign
nations
in a true madrid spirit
sophie that question was a bit garbled
but i think you were asking dr tedros
and mr locoque if there is now political
commitment
to help the nations that the less
wealthy nations
is that correct
[Music]
me
on it's madibas day tomorrow as you said
sophie and
you know something that we can learn
from his legacy especially being in this
situation is
what he had said which i would like to
quote
it always seems impossible until
it is done
that's very important i think
um considering what we're confronting
with now
it gives hope that we can defeat this
pandemic
so i repeat again the quote it always
seems impossible until it's done
and as we said before it's never too
late
anything can be turned around but we
have to push on
with the courage and commitment that we
have learned
from madiba that's one
and the second one is um
it you know something that i am reminded
when i think about madiba is his
commitment to
health he was a very very
strong believer of health for all
of course it comes from his belief
about equality so
that also is very important i think when
we
build back our world
it should be with real
commitment to health for all to
universal health coverage
so these are the two things i remember
which are very relevant to where we are
now
in our situation uh from mandela from
uh madiba uh
and thank you so much toby sophie for
that question and the second
i'm not sure if um mark had had listen
but it's in relation to mark's uh
statement mark are you there
yeah titles thank you very much indeed
and
thank you for what you just said as well
i completely agree with what you've
um what you just said so um
i want to draw a contrast if i may
between
the global response for um
the 2009 financial crisis where there
was good coordination a real stepping up
um by the better off countries through
the g20 particularly in reinforcing the
international monetary fund and the
world bank
to help the poorer countries is that
there's an unfortunate contrast between
that and what we're seeing now
this is a much bigger crisis and every
country is affected by it
but unfortunately we don't yet have a
commensurate response from the wealthier
countries in support of the poorer
countries
um and our advice is that
that's that needs to change if the
whole world does not want to look back
in two or three years time
at multiple cascading crises and wonder
why we didn't address them better
because we can prevent the worse still
there's no need for the world to see
multiple famines
stalking the planet in the next six or
nine months but we won't prevent it
unless we act differently
and i think it's timely to flag these
issues
ahead of the meeting of g20
finance ministers to encourage them
to think about what more they can do in
the way they acted in 2009
so thank you for your question and for
the chance to make those points
thank you very much oh mike i just uh
just one thought on on the great day
tomorrow i remember one
great quote from from from the great man
who said do not judge me by my successes
but judge me by how many times i fell
down and got back up again
and i think that's where we are now with
um
with kobit 19 in so many places
thank you we all agree with that
i'll now hand the question to stephanie
from reuters stephanie could you unmute
yourself and go ahead
yes hello thank you for taking my
question yeah it's regarding an update
please on the uh who advanced mission
that's been in china for
a week now the two experts um in
quarantine but negotiating
terms of access and a plan for the wider
mission
do you expect them to return to geneva
anytime soon and do you
expect a wider w.h.o wh international
mission to still get to china
say in july or hear any other details
on its composition as well thank you
we're working towards towards all of
those goals
our advanced team continues to engage
with various
scientific and health groups and science
and technology groups in
in china and we're also
reaching out now to experts
around the world trying to build an
advance a
a team that can be proposed to to go and
carry out
a later mission to implement researcher
studies and
with with colleagues in china it is
going to take some time where
obviously with the arrival and
quarantine of
individuals and working remotely is not
the ideal way to work but
we fully respect the the risk management
procedures that are in place they're in
there for
everybody's safety and for everyone's
health um
and i think at this point
it's unrealistic giving the timelines
and given the logistics that we would
expect
a full mission to be going to the fields
in in july because just
in terms of the timing and in terms of
pulling that team together
this is going to be a multi-national
team
with many experts from a number of
different countries with a number of
different expertises
bringing that team together and then
bringing that team into
into china to work with chinese
colleagues is is going to take just from
purely logistics
and health risk management perspective
weeks not days so uh i would not like to
put a
time of arrival for the team but we are
very pleased uh with the collaboration
on on on the ground and we would
obviously like to see a concrete plan of
action
with the remaining gaps in the remaining
areas that require further study and
elaboration
to be clearly elucidated and and to be
pursued by that team
with our colleagues in china and due
course
thank you very much dr ryan um the next
person on the line
is costas from the greek television
station
ert costas could you unmute yourself and
go ahead please
can you hear me very clearly please go
ahead
thank you for taking my question you've
been talking in recent weeks about
how the coronaviruses transmitted
through droplets and
maybe the air i would like to ask you
if the transmission of the corona virus
can happen
in the orifical way and
under what conditions and what is your
opinion on the use of face
shields and no masks that we see in
restaurants and cafes thank you
so i i can i can start with that
question but i'm sorry i'm going to go
back to stephanie's question very
quickly because i was just thinking of
how she asked the question where she
said
if we are negotiating terms of access
and i just wanted to touch upon that to
say that what's happening right now
is a discussion between our who
colleagues and our chinese counterparts
in terms of learning about what studies
have been done what studies need to be
done
in that collaborative fashion so i i
just wanted to touch about
touch upon that going to kostas's
question about
roots of transmission or transmission
thank you for bringing this question
up um we get a lot of questions about
transmission and people focus on either
droplets or they focus on
aerosols or they focus on fecal oral or
they focus on lots of different modes
but i think what we really need to be
thinking about and
mike you may want to touch upon this we
need to think about not only how
the virus transmits in terms of whether
it's these respiratory droplets or
aerosols or fecal oral
but when it transmits in terms of the
course of the infection from an
individual
and where transmission occurs and that
means the setting in which
the virus has an opportunity to pass
from an infected person
to another individual and that we need
to take into consideration
the context the intensity of that
contact
and the duration of that contact and i
think we need to start thinking of it in
that way because there are so many
different ways in which we can
minimize our risk and in many situations
prevent
transmission from moving from one
infected individual to another
with regard specifically to the fecal
oral there are some studies that are
looking at
a sampling stool in infected patients
and many of those have found rna
fragments
through pcr testing not viable virus
or infectious virus but fragments of
the virus itself and there are a lot of
people that are looking at the
possibility of a fecal oral transmission
we haven't seen that demonstrated but it
is something that it that is that
scientists are looking at but again just
to reiterate that there even though we
find
rna uh in stool samples it doesn't mean
that that is infectious
and it doesn't mean that that someone
can transmit between
the the infected stool to another
individual
thank you very much dr van kerkov uh dr
brian's got something to
no just again back to the the general
message from maria which i think is
important again
it is really important that we continue
to pursue all of the knowledge regarding
the various potential modes of
transmission
of this virus so that we can continue to
adapt the various control measures
we also always need to ask ourselves
what does this mean in our daily lives
what does this mean for our day-to-day
ability to protect ourselves and protect
our families
and i think within this we need to
continually reflect
on the settings that we put ourselves in
the situations and the context danger is
all about context
it's all situational and being
situationally aware
having situational awareness where am i
what
group am i in is this a safe environment
for me
for my children for my family can i
reduce the risk of this environment
so it's all about the setting it is
about the duration you spend on that
setting and it's about the intensity of
the activities that you participate
in in that setting and with
you get into a particular setting a very
overcrowded situation
uh with in an indoor environment then
effectively all bets are off because so
many of the modes of transmission come
into play
the the aerosol roof the airborne route
the full miter contamination route
so so the more and close you are to
other people the more you are inside the
more the activity is intense or involves
very close social contact the more
that multiple modes of transmission come
into play
so in that sense it is about you
understanding your risk
it is about you managing that risk and
being aware of the situation that you
find yourself in personally and reducing
that risk for you for your family for
your children
for your for your community it is
important
as i've said previously that governments
communicate those risks
very very carefully and it is also
important that
providers authorities and others ensure
that those environments are as safe
as possible and that the risks are also
managed and we don't know what the
perfect combination is of of
interventions
but what we do know is if individuals
and communities
are very aware of those risks very aware
of the virus transmission in the area if
the authorities
are taking action to ensure that people
are safe
safe in schools safe and restaurants
safe in buildings
and if all of that comes together in an
organized and
and understandable way for communities
in the main those countries those areas
control this virus
so it's not one thing it's not just
about the
the the issue of masks or it's not just
about
the issue of hand washing it's not just
about the issue of lockdowns or
stay-at-home orders or any
it is a combination of measures in which
the
community in partnership with each other
and in partnership with the authorities
come to a sustainable way of controlling
and suppressing
the transmission of the virus and living
with the virus in a way that normal
human activity can resume in a
successful way
and i think it's it's very important
then
that science continues to further
understand the dynamics of human
transmission to see if any adjustments
need to be made to those measures
thank you very much dr ryan so we now
have a question
from antonio from the spanish news
agency
fa antonio please go ahead and mute
yourself and please go ahead
antonio are you there
i think we have you're there okay please
go ahead
sorry okay i will make my question in in
spanish
[Music]
[Music]
a
so that was a question for mr lowcock uh
mr loco did you get that the question
was
there are 13 countries oh you got it all
okay
over to you i got it thank you so much
yeah
well um what we will do is we will send
you
um there's quite a lot of detail about
this so we'll send you some detail
um in paper or following on but the
the basic point to understand is that
these huge economic and social pressures
that people are facing and the decline
in availability of basic services health
services
um and so on adds to the
fragility and the stresses and the
drivers of conflict what we've seen
unfortunately
really over the last um 10 years on the
planet
is lots of pressures accumulating in
different parts of the world obviously
in the middle east across the sahel
in other parts of africa increasingly
in other parts of the world as well
which are unleashing
very hard to control forces
opening up the space for conflict and in
some case
cases opening up the space for
extremists to operate
conflicts all have causes they have
origins
and often those origins are um in part
economic or resource based
what we know about conflict also is that
when they start they're very hard to
stop
and they have consequences way beyond
the places where they start
and you know the one of the big messages
we're trying to convey
through this cost of inaction report
that we released alongside the
update of the humanitarian response plan
for kobe 19
is we are seeing all those drivers
build up and pile up and we know
that that has consequences thank you
and maybe i could supplement america's
our teams
work together every day when we look at
countries in
in humanitarian context and those
countries deeply fragile and vulnerable
through
the processes that mark refers to
historically over the last number of
years 70 of the high impact epidemics
around the world occur in those settings
and that's where we end up
end up operating uh a lot of the time
like we have teams in congo today for
teams
in the field for one and a half years
being for
all all over the world so in that sense
the health security of the world is
threatened by the fact that there are
not
strong surveillance and response systems
in place in these fragile settings
that's a threat to the people in those
areas
and that's a threat to the world so as
the cost of doing nothing
and the cost of non-intervention is not
just in the areas it is a global
consequence
of inaction and we really need to look
at that secondly
when we look at our collective goals
in terms of reaching the sustainable
development goals and bringing better
health
and social justice to the world the fact
is that
[Music]
the highest rates of maternal and child
mortality are occurring
in these same countries we will not
reach our goals on childhood mortality
on maternal mortality we will not reach
our goals and immunization for the world
unless we learn to do better in
supporting these countries
in conflict in deep fragility so
therefore it is
there is a massive cost of inaction
both on kobe but on so many other things
in these countries so we stand with mark
and the
interagency standing committee and our
um partners in really highlighting
that the issues are rising long-term uh
issues arising
in in conflict are not only impacting
the people in those areas but have a
major implication
for the rest of the planet and it is in
our enlightened self-interest
to address this this is not just the
right thing to do it is the smart thing
to do
thank you very much mr lokok and dr ryan
we now have
byram from andalu the turkish agency
byron please unmute yourself and go
ahead
thank you so much for taking my question
um
we keep on hearing a different reports
about whether or not people can believe
the infected with kobe 19 after getting
the virus
and then being cured what is the who's
current
assets assessment of this thank you so
much
thank you for the question um yes this
is this is an important question that
we've been
asked quite a lot lately in terms of if
someone can be reinfected with
coven 19. so what we understand and this
is a this is an area of active research
by scientists all over the world
clinicians all over the world
what we understand from people who are
infected with the sars cov2 virus
the virus that causes covid19 is that
they will develop an immune response
they will develop
antibodies neutralizing antibodies and
an immune response
that will provide some protection
against reinfection
what we don't know right now is how
strong that protection is
and for how long that protection will
last and we need answers to those
questions to be able to determine if
someone can be reinfected
after that immunity wears off so this is
an area of active active research
for the specific sars kovi ii virus
we do have some answers for other
coronaviruses
the mers coronavirus and the sars one
corona of cassar's cov1
coronavirus which emerged in 2003
indicating that people have an immunity
that lasts over 12 months or so and
maybe even longer
and we have some results from the human
coronaviruses the common
cold coronaviruses that circulate the
globe regularly
and your protection lasts a lot shorter
than that so
we don't have a complete answer but it
is an area of active research and i
should say an
active collaborative research all over
the world
thank you very much dr van kerkov and dr
ryan
uh now we have a question from bianco
from globo in brazil
bianca please go ahead unmute yourself
and please go ahead
hi margaret can you hear me very well
bianca please go ahead
many thanks for your attention for
taking my question
and so um journalists from global news
and global tv brazil
i i know that brazil is between the 63
countries that
um mark locog mentioned where
people need humanitarian assistance
so i would like to hear from mark how
concerned
are you mark with the situation there in
brazil
and from dr tedders or dr ryan if they
can give
us an updated general view of the
challenge
brazil is facing now with more than two
million cases
thanks a lot
okay uh this one's for mr low [ __ ] so
we'll go to mr lowcock first and then
we've got some things to say in the room
too
well thank you very much um
the main activity of the humanitarian
agencies which i coordinate in brazil
relates to
support for brazil in the way they are
helping
people who've left venezuela
and brazil like colombia peru ecuador a
range of other countries
um has taken a large burden of
supporting helping support millions of
venezuelans
who for reasons everyone's familiar with
have
in recent years left their country
um now um it's probably important for me
also to say that we recognize that
brazil itself has a
very substantial problem and i know that
ted ross and mike will talk about
who's perspective on that and the
support and so on but
what the humanitarian agencies do
is focus their effort on the very
poorest
countries so brazil um country obviously
which has developed a lot over recent
decades
has typically not needed assistance from
humanitarian agencies in the way say
some african countries or
some countries caught up in conflict um
have done
so we did not at the moment and we hope
we
never need to